- [Interviewer] What's your favorite thing
about these ladies down here?
- I like to pound 'em.
Yeah.
I like to get on top and just
fuck the shit out of 'em.
Bottom line.
- [Interviewer] All right, Bob.
Bob, where are you from originally?
- [Bob] Los Angeles.
- [Interviewer] LA, and tell
me about your childhood.
You grew up with both your parents?
- [Bob] Oh no, my parents
immigrated from the Soviet Union
and I have two younger sisters.
- [Interviewer] But you
had a normal childhood?
- I had a rough childhood.
- [Interviewer] How's that?
- My father immigrated
from the Soviet Union.
He was a boxer, he was
a German, he escaped.
And he was a KGB agent.
He was the mayor of a
city in the Soviet Union,
champion chess player, and a playboy.
And he used to beat my mother up a lot.
- [Interviewer] Oh really?
- I witnessed him hittin' her
and she knocked down
and blood came out of her mouth.
She would get back up
and he'd knock her again,
and she would fall down.
Typical boxer, he liked
to drink Schlitz beer.
- [Interviewer] And any
abuse for you as well?
- Yes, he used to beat me
with a plunger and a belt.
- [Interviewer] Wow.
What careers, what jobs did you have?
- I was, well that, after
I delivered the LA Times,
I went to school and I became a,
eventually I became one of
the youngest officers appointed
in Bank of America's history in my 20s.
- [Interviewer] Oh, so
you worked at a bank?
- Bank of America on
525 South Flower Street
and branch 600 at that time.
It's no longer there now.
- [Interviewer] And so that was the
majority of your career was banking?
- Yeah so banker, and
then after that I married
my first wife, Diana and
that didn't go well.
I ended up in a mental ward.
And then I met my second wife
that I married in Genoa, Italy.
And I went through a divorce with her,
ended up in a mental ward.
And now I'm single and free;
I don't have a ring on my ring finger.
And I'm single and free
and I'm happy to be alive
and I love life and I
live it to the fullest.
I live it to the fullest,
like I believe in, "God
give it, God take it."
And I believe that to tell
the truth is the only truth.
And I'm sorry, you were gonna ask--
- [Interviewer] I was gonna say,
so you like to pick up some of
the girls down here in Skid Row?
- I do.
We have a party and we,
I give them money so that they
can take care of themselves.
And, you know, right now I just
smoke cigarettes and cigars
and I drink fluids.
I'm drug-free, alcohol-free.
If you take my blood now
I have no illegal drugs in my system
and I believe that we
all bleed the same color,
so I respect all citizens, nationalities,
religion, creeds, and all the above.
- [Interviewer] So you had drugs
and alcohol problems in the past?
- Yes I did, my main choice was cocaine.
And I haven't done that
in a long long time.
- [Interviewer] That's great.
How often do you come down here
to pick up some of the ladies?
- [Bob] Oh, when they run in to me,
I help 'em out like you do.
Like I say, you know, "You
wanna come over and party?"
- [Interviewer] So, are there other girls
other than Vicky that you have fun with?
- [Bob] Yes, girls, ladies, women, yeah.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, exactly.
Sorry, women.
- [Bob] She's all one, Vicky.
- [Interviewer] Yes she is.
And how often will you
come down here to do this?
- [Bob] I live at the Lincoln Hotel,
and I run into them periodically
and I have phone numbers for all kinds of
people and contacts for
all kinds of people.
And it's hard to trust who's who.
- [Interviewer] So you'll come down here,
pick up some of the girls on weekends?
- [Bob] Oh yeah, they come
to my, like Vicky, like
she'll come and she'll,
I'll come down and let her up
like I did this morning
and she told me about you,
and Mark.
- [Interviewer] So you'll
have intercourse or oral sex?
- [Bob] No, with her, never intercourse.
Just, you know, private encounters,
safe sex, all that good stuff.
And there's other persons that I have
intimate relationships, like Keesha.
I eat her pussy out and--
- [Interviewer] What about
some of the sexually trans--
- [Bob] No I don't.
I'm HIV undetectable
and I don't have AIDS.
I take my medicines.
- [Interviewer] So HIV
undetectable means what?
- That means I can't pass it on.
- [Interviewer] So you have it?
- I have it.
- [Interviewer] You do?
- Yes, like Magic Johnson.
He came out with AIDS and now he's on--
- [Interviewer] Where do
you think he got that?
- I was raped years ago
in an apartment building
on the second floor
on the corner of Broadway
and Century Boulevard.
And I woke up one morning
and he was sucking my cock.
He was French, Francois-like,
and he was sucking my cock
and I wanted to fuck him up,
I wanted to kill him.
And all of a sudden I
realized that I was high,
if I would have killed him
I would've gone to jail,
or prison and I let it go.
And I went to the Downtown Mental Health
and I saw my psychiatrist
and she said, "You might wanna
have your eyes examined."
And I said, "Why?"
And she said, "For AIDS."
So I went to primary care physician,
at that time the LA
Christian Health Center,
Joshua House also known as,
and they took a blood test
and I went for the results and he said,
"I have some bad news for you."
And I said, "What's that?"
He said, "You're HIV infected
and you need medicine."
So I was taking all
kinds of medicine for HIV
and I went to 826 West 104
Street, South Central LA,
picked up my phone, called
my younger sister Tanya,
she did 20 years in the
army, and I told her.
She was the first person I told
that I was infected with HIV.
So anyway, it's a new day.
And I have a younger
sister, younger than her,
in Phoenix, Arizona.
And I plan on visiting her next month.
So anyway, I'm cool.
- [Interviewer] You seem healthy.
- Yeah, I am healthy.
I'm losing weight, I'm
staying on an even keel,
I have a sponsor for
alcoholism, and for NA.
No, that's okay, it's I'm a man,
and his name's Donald.
He also lives at the Lincoln
Hotel on the third floor.
As a matter of fact,
I have a meeting tonight at eight o'clock.
- [Interviewer] Excellent.
- Narcotics Anonymous meeting.
I went to a lot of AA
meetings and NA meetings
and I got the chips 'n shit
and I plan on keep going to meetings.
And I believe in The Twelve Steps.
And I have a Bible that I read daily.
- [Interviewer] Excellent,
you done a good job
getting away from a lot
of these substances.
- Yeah, I try to weed out all
the bad people from my life.
- [Interviewer] Great, so you've been
married a couple times. Do you--
- I've been married a couple times.
I'm looking for a third wife
and I believe the third one is the charm.
- [Interviewer] Do you enjoy or prefer
these kind of free
relationships where you're--
- No I don't.
- [Interviewer] You'd
rather be settled down.
- I think I wanna meet somebody at church.
- [Interviewer] So your relationship
with the ladies that you pick up
is your--
- Platonic.
- You treat them nicely.
- I do, I'll wine-and-dine 'em
and I treat 'em with
the best of my ability.
- Yeah, 'cause you know a lot of girls
have told me stories
about guys getting rough
and all that kinda stuff.
- Well, you know what?
You can tell something to somebody,
but if they don't have a good memory
or they're high at the time,
they can twist it and
tell a different version
of what happened.
And that's where you can get mixed up.
- [Interviewer] What's your favorite thing
about pickin' up some of the girls
here on the street?
- Girls?
Wine-and-dine 'em and having sex.
- [Interviewer] But, what's
your favorite aspect of,
what's your favorite thing
about these ladies down here?
- I like to pound 'em.
Yeah, I like to get on top
and just fuck the shit out of 'em.
Bottom line.
That's what my father did to my mother.
He was a playboy, like I said,
and my mother lived to me 83
and my father to be 72.
I'm 61, I'll be 62 July 12th, 1958.
- [Interviewer] All right Bob.
Well thank you so much for talk to me
and being so open.
- You're welcome Mark.
- [Interviewer] Thank you.
- You all have a great rest of your day
and see you when I see you,
talk to you when I talk to you.
- [Interviewer] All right man, thank you.
- You're welcome.